as he's got his game face on ready to
face odubal herrera now for the ball
game on the first pitch swung on a fly
ball down the left field line tracking
eddie rosario into foul ground and he
gets this first one under his belt after
that error last night he picks up out
number one squeezing it right next to
the tarp and found territory down the
left field line gene segura has been a
pest all year long against the atlanta
staff now the 1-2
is on the ground golf to riley austin's
got it and a strike to first two outs
and that's his first of the night
tonight with bryce harper standing in
2-2 pitch on the way
got him
swung on and missed at a 96 mile an hour
fastball that pitch as joe mentioned has
been the difference maker of late for
max and he showcases it here to in the
top of the first hitting and they'll
face arenola making his 32nd start of
the season
he's 9-8 with an era of 4.64
his last eight starts in atlanta one in
five with an era of 5.23
on the ground a base hit and that's the
other problem he's about to get to it
erin nola
has now given up 77 two strike hits this
year and riley tries to dump one behind
first fearling long run still going he
can't get it ball drops solaire never
stopped running one nothing on a blue
pit from riley
what an incredible job by solaire right
here taking a chance with that read
going and when freddie saw solaire ago
he took off too he almost caught this
that brings duval up to the plate and he
has been the man with runners in scoring
position to duvall and a ground ball
poked the other way
segura is going to get one throw to
first is going to be late
graves put it in play again and get a
second run give duval number 112.
freddie freeman scores it's two nothing
atlanta playoff kind of at bats 100
against the playoff type pitcher and the
braves with two runs here in the bottom
of the first inning a one-two pitch on
the way crown ball tapper into the shift
that'll be taken by gregorius the
shortstop on the right side of the
infield and he fires over to matt
bierling for out number three but the
braves out to a really good start all
right so the phillies have something
going here first and third and it brings
terrace up
off the hands slowly to the right side
all beast has it pirouettes and throws
it right on by freddie freeman a run
scores over to third is dede gregorius
and the phillies are on the board it's a
2-1 game
you see ozzie get to this ball i think
he thought he was going to have less
time and it would have been bang bang he
just pulled the throw 32 pitches for
nola one out in the second max freight
is next first the one-two pitch dansby
drives one toward right center field
harker on the run not gonna get that
that's high off the wall densbe flying
for two he's going to slide in safely
and if you want to get him back jeff
that's the spot two balls two strikes
and the pitch swinging a miss got him
with a curveball
and aaron nola strikes out freddie
freeman it's his first strikeout of the
night and a great time for it
as he keeps the braves off the board no
runs a hit to left we're going to the
third
dribbler dansby charges
gets rid of it fast great play
don't you see what dansby did there
as he charged in jeff played it to the
side so he could get momentum in his
favor absolutely he knew he had one
chance at this with where the ball was
hit and how softly smeared can run
two one braves bottom of the third eddie
rosario's over one with a ground out
braves looking to get something going
with two down here in the bottom of the
third inning now the one-two pitch
runner goes pitches hammer toward right
harper on the run not gonna get there
that falls down ozzy around third is
gonna score
rosario with a double atlanta extends
the lead
and a lightning bolt out to right off
the wall by eddie rosario and he picks
up his 60th rbi of the year and it's 3-1
braves
and the braves with a 3-1 lead facing
the top of the order for the third time
the top five hitters a combined 0 for 10
tonight
for the phillies 1-0 swung on hit deep
right field going back is solari looks
up and this one is off the wall bangs
away from him and duvall has to pick it
up in right center and it's a double for
o'double off of max freed
and that's the first hit for the
phillies
since the torreyas infield hit in the
second inning segura is grounded out
twice both times to the left side
well runner at third base infield back
and again one's got to be the minimum
here
ground ball out to shortstop oh duple's
going to score
swanson throws out segora it's a 3-2
game rbi for segura 58 runs batted in
for gene 2-2 pitch and harper strikes
out for the third time he's got the hat
trick all swinging all fastballs six
innings in the books braves up by a
skinny run three to two three with six
strikeouts nine ground outs through six
and two thirds innings
high pop
freight is going to pitch seven innings
tonight austin reilly is under it he's
got it what a night for max freed
so down they go one two three in the
seventh that's the fifth one two three
inning for max free
oh two comebacker that finds a hole in a
basin in the center
so there oh the oh double herrera
overruns the ball everybody will advance
solaire was heading to second herrera
came up with everything but the ball
that's a big break for the braves
that'll be a single and an error on
herrera and now naris inherits runners
at second and third one out for riley
sharply headed down the line that's
gonna score two
another two strike hit this one from
austin riley and the braves break the
game open
5-2 atlanta here in the seventh that's a
huge knock well here we go [ __ ] rod
comes out pitch on the way to dansby
swings and a shot up the middle past the
diving gregorius base hit up the middle
and to score riley coming also to the
plate and scoring rosario
and dansby goes right up the middle and
comes through with a huge base hit it's
7-2
sounded like he might have broken his
back but it had just enough on it to get
up get by a diving deity gregorius oh i
think he splintered it but strong enough
to get it through
very close ball game for six and a half
innings it was 3-2 braves going into the
bottom of the seventh
and the braves sent 10 men to the plate
in the bottom of the seventh inning
scored four times pitch on the way
ground ball weakly out to short dansby
charges he scoops he fires over and the
braves are one win away
they win tonight seven to two over the
phillies
a one two three nine for rodriguez and
it's the seventh inning
that holds up for the braves
brilliant pitching in the first two
games of this series seven innings for
morton last night seven innings from
three tonight and the bats did the work
late